[Musique]
c'était le 2 décembre 2020 vers 16h50 17
heures donc en plein hiver fin de
journée
c'était encore en confinement et morgane
est allé couper du bois dans ce bosquet
ici qui se trouve à une centaine de
mètres de sa maison
il avait un casque orange une
tronçonneuse est en fait assez aux
alentours de 16h50 17 heures il ya un
chasseur qui l'a pris pour un sanglier
et qu'il qui attire et qui l'a touché au
thorax
il a été il ya eu une tentative de
réanimation
et
mais au final il est décédé quelques
minutes après
lendemain il ya le procureur du lot qui
a dit que toutes les règles de sécurité
avaient été respectées
du coup on s'est dit mais comment
comment il peut y avoir
le un assassinat du d'un homme alors que
des règles de sécurité ont été
respectées ça veut dire que les règles
ne sont pas du tout suffisante il ya
quand même une différence de taille
entre un sanglier un homme debout au
thorax
c'est c'est ça en fait on comprend pas
comment à partir de quel point un
chasseur peut confondre un humain d'un
mètre 90 avec un sanglier
merci à tous et à toutes d'être là ça me
fait plaisir de vous voir et je sais que
ça aurait fait pas plaisir à morgane
aussi
bien sûr on n'a pas oublié les
circonstances dans laquelle il est mort
tué dans son jardin à 25 ans à cause du
soi-disant loisirs de certains
nous allons pas oublier le choc n'ont
pas oublié leurs heures ni la
compréhension de ce moment nous n'avons
pas oublié
et nous ne l'avons pas par l'onu
c'est un ami qui m'a vu grandir je pense
qu'il faut réguler ça en tout cas ces
rapports qu'on a avec la chasse parce
que mon habitants campagne on a peur en
fait enfin la jeune fille on attend de
se balader quoi je trouve que la chasse
prendre trop de trop de place dans les
campagnes moi je vis à la campagne
et quand on se promène je suis trop si
pour moi c'est une agression
- c'est audrey à côté de moi y'a zoé on
représente le collectif un jour un chat
ça nous avons mis en ligne sur le site
du sénat une pétition
pour que le sénat écoute nos demandes
donc nous demandons le mercredi et le
dimanche sans chasse un renforcement des
distances de sécurité par rapport aux
habitations dans trois jours il y aller
et miller qui sont donc les autres
personnes du collectif a maintenant les
a mis là sont auditionnés au sénat pour
ouvrir donc la mission control qui a été
ouverte par le parquet n'a certainement
que morgane est mort et ça fait un an
qu'on continue non lâche rien je fournis
sur la première lâcher on va continuer
voilà merci à tous
[Musique]
je pense qu'à des rares sont celles qui
ornent les assimilent à deux amis
d'enfance de morgane qui ne se
rejoignent pas paris elles vivent
maintenant à l'étranger mais reste
active dans le collectif créé après sa
mort en fait c'est c'est quelque chose
qu'on va distribuer
sénateurs qui seront présents et qui
rassemble les textes qu'on ait fait donc
les différentes tribunes la pétition et
le communiqué qu on a fait quand le
sénat sont assiégés dans quelques heures
elles seront auditionnés au sénat une
chambre à l'image plutôt pro chasse
bien non natation
le 2 décembre 2020 un plein confinement
notre ami d'enfance et voisins morgan
tine a été abattu par un chasseur qui
l'aurait confondu avec un sanglier alors
qu'il coupait du bois dans son jardin
avec une tronçonneuse je pense que tu
peux parler un petit peu près un peu
plus fluide vrai way
très vite nous avons pris conscience
après la mort de leur ami les soutiens
et témoignages ont afflué de toute la
france de plus en plus nombreux c'est
comme ça qu'est née l'idée d'une
pétition sur le site du sénat pour que
les sénateurs sont saisissent il faut
récolter 100 mille signatures en six
mois l'objectif a été atteint en
seulement deux mois
c'est des gens qui n'ont jamais pu
s'exprimer qu'ils sont un bain des gens
des campagnes en général des ruraux et
pour qui c'était très compliqué de dire
ce qu'il ressentait et le fait de leurs
avoirs enfin je pense du coup
qu'aujourd'hui à locaux gens derrière
nous parce que on a permis à ces gens-là
une voix en fait c'est qu'elle est
visible
[Musique]
de là
alors mes chers collègues nous débutons
véritablement aujourd'hui les travaux de
la mission conjointe de contrôle sur la
sécurisation à la chasse par l'audition
de l'auteur de la pétition madame myriam
sanchez accompagné de madame léa
jaillard je vais vous laisser la parole
pour une vingtaine de minutes apôtres
est sûr remercié
depuis maintenant un an nous recevons
chaque jour une vingtaine de témoignages
faisant état entre autres deux
sentiments d'insécurité et de peur
d'aller se promener en raison de battu
non signalée de tirs dans des maisons
des chambres d'enfants des salons des
jardins des trains et des voitures en
circulation
donc on demande d'abord l'interdiction
de la chasse le mercredi et le dimanche
le territoire national 82% des français
sont favorables à cette mesure nos
voisins européens ont pour la plupart
déjà adopté au moins un jour
hebdomadaire sans chasse dont jean
mathia leur seule possibilité donc ce
qu'ils disent de chasser mais c'est
mieux c'est pareil pour les gens qui
veulent se promener dans la nature les
familles les enfants donc en fait là il
ya vraiment une priorité afin qu'ils
aient donné à un type d'activité plutôt
que les autres nous demandons une
distance de sécurité autour des maisons
des routes et des chemins au moins égale
à la distance maximale de porter des
armes un législateur qui prend le risque
de faire cohabiter 98% de la population
avec 2 % de chasseurs dans les bals sont
incontrôlables et létal jusqu'à 3 km et
qui le sait est donc responsable des
accidents qui peuvent en découler merci
à vous pour ces témoignages on a beau
être au courant des des drames liés à la
chasse c'était poignant touchant daniel
salmon est l'un des 19 membres de la
mission d'information sur la
sécurisation de la chasse le seul à
avoir un avis tranché sur la question
écologistes il est favorable aux
propositions de millas et léa le but de
cette mission c'est d'avoir des
préconisations et derrière des
préconisations il peut tout à fait y
avoir une loi je pense qu'on ne pourra
pas s'arrêter au milieu du gué
aujourd'hui il ya des attentes
sociétales il faut qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout
sur la saison 2020-2021 80 accidents ont
été recensés en france dont 7 mortels
la plupart ont eu lieu lors d'une chasse
au grand gibier
pour leur premier déplacement de terrain
les sénateurs vont donc suivre une
battue au sanglier
en préambule à l'organisation de la
chasse on va parler les conseils de
sécurité de la traque qui va se dérouler
aujourd'hui en fin de la chasse qui va
dérouler aujourd'hui donc les
déplacements pour aller au poste et en
revenir s'effectueront à pied à mme
cassez ou culasse ouvertes et dans tous
les cas totalement vide en présence de
toute personne étrangère à l'action de
chasse vont des vtt des promeneurs ou
qui que ce soit vous déchargez votre
arme vous restez courtois c'est le moins
que l'on puisse faire
le principe d'une battue est simple un
groupe de chasseurs traquent le gibier à
l'aide de chiens et le rabat vers une
ligne de tireurs enfin gérard qu'elle a
positionné à quelques mètres les uns des
autres les tireurs postés doivent
absolument respecter un angle de tir de
30 degrés
le niveau de confort tant la wii total
château un caméléon de sauveteurs oui la
droite ligne en face c'est ok a accouché
futur donc
l'angle de 30 degrés a été calculée pour
réduire au maximum le risque qu'une
balle ricoche et touche le terrain
voisin c'est une règle de sécurité
fondamentales
80% des victimes sont des chasseurs
ceux typiquement du chevreuil a déterré
des traces comme ça c'est génial mais
nous en bretagne rarement de la neige
sinon que ben on le voit ça dans la vie
quand il ya un peu 2 debout frêche
la droite val que vous mettiez l'annoncé
pour un trimestre sept mines m me monte
jusqu'à 9h sur nos ballons en dix ans
moyen calibre moyen
est déjà assez conséquent pour moi
le choix du poste est stratégique
celui ci est idéal pour réaliser des tir
fichant tir fichant c'est ainsi en
direction du terrain pour que la balle
l albien se planter dans le terrain
et qu'elle parte pas n'importe où par
exemple si vous avez une ligne de crête
est un animal en ligne de crête six tirs
droit là et qu'ils loupent l'animal ma
balle elle pas croyez elle part à 10 km
or si vous tirez dans la pente ou d'un
sol ou tirer au delà il va aller se
planter deux dans des balles perdues il
devrait pas y en avoir quand on entend
bouger on tire pois cours tant qu'on a
pas vu l'animal comme il faut en
3d tir fichant dans un angle de 30
degrés sur une cible bien identifiés sur
le papier l'accident est presque
impossible
si je pense que c'est un peu exemplaire
on est venu il faut être faut être clair
fait sénateurs sont là on est avec des
gens très compétents qui nous explique
clairement quelles sont les règles de
sécurité qui les rappelle à chaque
instant et donc on est dans les
conditions entre guillemets idéal mais
il faudrait d'autres expériences pour
savoir si lorsqu'il n'ya pas des
sénateurs dans le secteur ça se passe de
la même manière
bon eh ben les fera pas de sangliers
j'avais prévu de ramener un cuissot mal
déçu chez moi
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas un hasard si daniel salmon
et membre de la mission d'information
sur la sécurisation de la chasse
partisan d'une réglementation plus
stricte il est aussi sénateur d'un
département qui vient de vivre un
accident traumatique
le 30 octobre dernier un homme est mort
au volant de sa voiture à hauteur de
laillé sur la quatre voies qui relie
rennes à nantes l'une des routes les
plus fréquentées d'ille-et-vilaine
voulais me raconter comment ça s'est
passé donc c'est ici que un
automobiliste monsieur viard a reçu une
balle tirée par un chasseur de de la
[__] là bas apparemment le l'impact a eu
lieu juste avant le pont là dans le bas
de la descente à lyon ball qu'elle fait
ça il est décédé le jeudi suivant
encore une fois l'accident a eu lieu
lors d'une battue à quelques centaines
de mètres de la route
le chasseur était
sûr
dans le champ au fond là bas qu'on peut
apercevoir derrière les arbres à au
moins entre 500 et 700 mètres de la
quatre voies est donc la balle est là
elle a longé la terre en fait parce
qu'il était en surplomb
le chasseur par rapport à la hauteur de
la cad voit la distance c'est
impressionnant quand on voit la densité
de la végétation la balle hélas
forcément rencontré très certainement
rencontrer quand même quelques petits
obstacles mais ça n'a pas arrêté quoi
elle n'a pas pris un tronc donc tant
qu'elle ne rencontre pas un tronc et
pasqua il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
se pose cette pauvre personnel était
vraiment là au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment c'est indéniable elle a
vraiment pas eu de chance simplement on
peut se dire que sans doute il ya eu
beaucoup de personnes qui ont eu de la
chance parce que c'est des endroits qui
sont très chassée ça veut dire qu'il ya
sans doute eu peut-être des centaines de
balles ou des milliers de balles qui ont
déjà traversé cette route sans
heureusement touché personne
des bals potentiellement mortelle qui
finissent leur course dans une voiture
où le toit d'une maison depuis 2014 ce
genre d'incident a progressé de plus de
160%
quelques jours seulement avant
l'accident mortel de l'ail et 10 km plus
loin cet habitant d'une commune voisine
a découvert une balle dans la chambre de
sa fille
elle accusait son frère qui avait fait
un trou dans le mur et du coup je suis
monté avec le petit dans la chambre
parce que moi je n'avais pas qu'il
m'avait pas quitter le petit quand j'ai
aperçu le trou je me suis dit oui ça
c'est sentir c'est une malle sait
et on a retrouvé l'ogive auprès de
derrière le lit
on peut circuler dans son lit quoi voilà
tout à fait ah bah oui en colère me met
en colère
par rapport à personne qui tire et ça
qu'ils prennent conscience qu'ils
auraient pu tuer une personne
ça c'est qu'ils prennent conscience
aussi qu'il a une arme dans les mains
c'est c'est c'est pour un pistolet
et d'autant plus en colère qu'il est
lui-même chasseur depuis plus de 30 ans
et donc vous faisait des battus jb je
suis pas retournée à la chasse depuis le
puits le 10 octobre shepparton à l'achat
sont bons je suis dégoûté lui a toujours
chasser au fusil beaucoup moins puissant
que les carabine utilisés dans les
battues est ce qu'une balle de carabine
là tout le monde en parle c'est mortel
entre 2000 et 5000 m
un fusil un calibre 12 je tirais 500
mètres minimum j'ai peut être mortelle
aussi je ne vais pas critiquer la
carabine mais la carabine y en avait pas
pour
son bon goût plus puissants
effectivement j'ai beaucoup plus
dangereux je suis assez ça rit parce que
dans ces deux contexte là on voit que
ses balles sont venues de très très loin
qu'elles ont franchi le carrément des
haies bocagères et qu'elle arrive et
qu'elles ont encore une puissance
phénoménale on est avec ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des armes de guerre et
la chasse ce n'est pas la guerre donc il
va falloir faire du ménage non à ce
niveau là
les chasseurs mais triste il vraiment
les armes parfois très puissante qui
l'ont à la main
pour le savoir la mission d'information
sénatoriale se rend dans l'un des sept
cinétyr que compte la france
alors qu'est ce qu'un psy n'attire
cinétyr c'est un simulateur qui permet à
balles réelles de tirer sur un écran
donc je ferme la culasse et lorsque je
veux tirer le film va se le film est
bloqué
vous voyez la pac donc ils avaient un
point rouge sur le sur le cou de
l'animal c'est le tir qui a été réalisé
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'avec cette technologie là si vous
tirez à côté par exemple dessous
vous voyez aussi l'impact ce qui permet
tout de suite aux tireurs va devoir
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'il a comme
comme défaut et avec mon aide l'analyse
et qu'est-ce qui va pas un manque de
pratique une peur de son arme ça j'en
suis intimement persuadé parce qu'une
arme c'est puissant ça génère un certain
recul
et certaines fois je suis obligé de dire
attention là vous avez vu ce que vous
avez fait on commence un peu à se
balader comme ça j vous avez vu la votre
canon la zone de sécurité c'est l'écran
dont canon toujours vers l'écran et
ambra le permis de chasse date de 76
depuis 2020 les chasseurs ont
l'obligation de suie une nouvelle
formation tous les dix ans une avancée
trop timide pour ce chasseur aguerri je
pense que une petite remise à niveau
tous les deux trois cinq ans je ne sais
pas serait grandement grandement
efficace pour en tout cas faire
comprendre aux gens qu'une arme massa se
manipule une certaine façon et pas d'une
autre par contre ne sont pas un amalgame
avec la puissance puisque on se rend
compte là aussi au niveau de
l'accidentologie qu il y as autant
d'accidents avec des armes que vous
qualifiez de puissantes qui sont les
carabines qu'avec des fusils de chasse
qui sont des dvd armes à canon lisse et
qui ont une portée qui est très très
très très réduite
et bien voilà une balle de tête parfait
[Musique]
légiférer sur les carabines utilisait
pour chasser le gros gibier n'est pas si
simple
daniel salmon retourne à l'ail et la
commune de son département où un
automobiliste a été tué par une balle
perdue
en craquant lancement les sangliers sont
de plus en plus nombreux et ravage les
terres des agriculteurs
tout ça c'est des gars non mais on voit
bien que tout est arraché quoi oui
oui les cap sur 10 cm de hauteur quoi
est pratiquement et donc on sait que la
colère va passer mort n'a manqué en
manque de fourrage quoi il n'y avait pas
que 1 sans briller pour faire tous ces
dégâts là c'est des bandes de sangliers
qui viennent toutes les nuits
régulièrement il ya plus de la moitié de
la parfum qui étaient touchés chaque
année les sangliers à dix huit hectares
des terres de ce couple une perte sèche
de 5000 euros c'est difficile
psychologiquement très difficile
certaines périodes
donc moi des fois je préfère même pas un
miroir là je viens avec vous ça me fait
mal au coeur quand on entend les
chasseurs ils disent que non la
population de sangliers n'a pas augmenté
moi je ne sais pas nous nous
agriculteurs on les voit en plein jour
vous allez pouvoir me slim à ben ali si
vous n'avez pas encore mais normalement
il n'y a pas de souci après l'accident
dramatique qui a coûté la vie à un homme
sur sa commune
la maire de lille a pris une décision
radicale
on a pris un arrêté sur la commune
interdisant toute action de chasse dans
les 150 mètres autour des habitations
obligeant
les chiens de chasse à être tenus en
laisse dans les 150 mètres autour des
habitations et interdisant le tir à la
carabine sur toute la commune vous
saviez que vous poussiez un peu le
bouchon loin mais c'était pour faire
réagir et voir un peu comment ça ça
pouvait évoluer derrière
la réaction n'a pas manqué très vite les
chasseurs ont rangé leurs armes et
globalement la chasse c'est complètement
arrêté le 11 novembre
parce que j'assure estimé qu'avec ces
restrictions il ne pouvait plus chasser
d'accord ils vous ont fait une petite
petite mesure de rétorsion en disant
vous allez beaucoup trop loin donc nous
on chasse plus du tout et vous allez
voir ce que ça va ce que ça va donner
c'est ça ok en peu de temps comme ça
vous avez vu une évolution les sangliers
sont approchés eu que les communes des
environs étaient chassés l'ail et
n'était plus à chasser
l'animal il est parfois donc en fait il
revenait sur la commune se réfugier dans
les bois de laillé ou sur les terres de
les y ai
vu que les autres communes continuent à
chasser quoi on va se laver les bottes
mener c'est par une surpopulation de
sangliers sur sa commune la mère a dû
faire marche arrière élevés sont arrêtés
on peut pas faire fi des dégâts qu'on a
vu ce matin et se faire comme si ça
n'existait pas on voit bien que ça amène
des gros soucis dans les exploitations
agricoles il certaine détresse non
seulement ça interroge mesures on se dit
qu'il faut réagir il faut arriver à
trouver des solutions et des chasseurs
ont certainement un rôle à jouer bien
entendu
[Musique]
andres edwards est aussi à l'aise pour
tirer un sanglier à la carabine de gros
calibre que pour traquer le petit gibier
armé de ses cartouches de plomb et de
son fusil alors aujourd'hui on chasse
dans le matin la forêt de brocéliande un
forêt légendaire alors comment ça
fonctionne et bien en pratique ce qu'on
appelle une chasse devant soi puisque on
chasse avec des déchets avis d'arrêt on
laisse qu'était le chien qui va nous
trouver les oiseaux et la voyez là-bas
l'instant on parle de chien est à
l'arrêt donc faut y aller parce qu'il a
trouvé un oiseau
c'est reparti
tu m'as vu tu là vous ai collé à wii 2
de la première qui se tiennent du parti
dans le dos celle ci qui nous a prétendu
c'est sa chasse à la bécasse qui s'est
passé pas dû c'est pas du tout qu un pas
loin s'en faut c'est leur défense mais
sont elles sont elles sont
extraordinaires c'est c'est cela c'est
sa nature
la partie intéressante de la chasse est
ce qui nous motive c'est tout ce qui
précède lac le tir est l'acte final une
des cases voyez là on peut au succès ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir le
chien parcourir l'espace attention c'est
un animal chasse pour son ventre donc
c'est vrai c'est certain la ceinture et
les chaluts l'homme l'a perdu de son
instinct sur elle même et chez mado
s'assied sur lui le côté le volet jours
sans chasse
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous qu'on
pourrait croire que ce serait une bonne
idée de dire je sais que ça allait on
lit souvent partenaires de l'ail et
dimanche son chef merci on commence
comme ça moi qui suis un ancien assureur
et qui connaît les statistiques
accidentogène il ya plein d'activités il
va falloir arrêter la voiture ces week
end qu'elles ont lieu alors si on veut
régler le problème des cils en faudra
peut-être interdit la circulation de
voitures sur vos moins d'accidents moins
de morts sur les routes si on commence à
interdire toutes les activités dimanche
parce qu'il ya un risque parce que ça
déplaît surtout à nuancer du dogmatisme
ça on pourrait on peut très bien
discuter localement trouver des
aménagements moi je deale par la
tolérance par la discussion le dialogue
pour dire peut-être que là dimanche
après midi sur la commune voyez les
communes urbaines suburbaines comme il
ya eu à la villa proche de rennes
guérande il l'a peut-être que localement
les gars peuvent dire on fera pas de
batterie dimanche après midi
comment partager la nature entre
chasseurs et non chasseurs
la mission d'information sénatoriale
devra prendre position
daniel seulement lui reste persuadé que
la solution passe par des journées sans
chasse mais le sénat réputé proche des
chasseurs dira-t-il jusque là
deux jours sans chasse j'y crois pas
trop je pense c'est la marche est trop
haute pour de nombreux sénateurs par
contre
une journée c'est possible et moi
j'estime que si on va pas sur une
demi-journée ça sera un échec
aujourd'hui les chasseurs ne sont
certainement pas majoritaires au sénat
par contre les gens issus du milieu
rural et sur lequel pèse encore le monde
de la chasse ils sont encore nombreux
mais
il ya une évolution justement c'est là
qu'on va voir où en est le sénat
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais
[Musique]